I get lots of comments and questions if Game
of Thrones prequel series is cancelled.
People say they are reading about it all over
the internet. The answer is yes, one Game
of Thrones prequel is cancelled, its name
was the Long Night or the Bloodmoon,
but the other Game of Thrones prequel series,
House of the Dragon,
about which I've been talking about on this
channel, is not.
The game of Thrones prequel series, House
of the Dragon, is in the process of filming
and will be released early on in 2022, or
in other words in just over one year.
Unlike the Long Night prequel, HBO ordered
the entire first season of House of the Dragon,
meaning that this prequel cannot be canceled.
HBO's prequel Bloodmoon was meant to fill
the gap that Game of Thrones left behind,
but the project has been canceled and replaced
with House of the Dragon. If the Long Night
prequel wasn't canceled, it would already
be out as 2020 was its official release date.
Bloodmoon was supposed to be about the Long
Night. At first, it seemed as if everything
was going just fine with it and HBO even filmed
a pilot, but for whatever reason, chose not
to turn it into a series. A pilot episode
was written and produced by Jane Goldman,
set thousands of years before Game of Thrones.
Hours after announcing that the Blood Moon
prequel was cancelled,
HBO announced that they ordered the entire
first season of House of the Dragon.
"Pilots – sometimes they come together,
sometimes they don’t,"
HBO's president Casey Bloys told Variety about
why the network decided to go with one prequel
series over the other. "And I would say that
was very much the case here.
There’s nothing I would point to and say
"Oh, this was the problem.'"
However, Bloys did reveal that since House
of the Dragon is based on Martin's writing,
it was easier for the show's creative team
to delve into the story of House Targaryen.
"That prequel was 8,000 years before the current
show, so it required a lot more invention,"
he explained. “One of the benefits of 'House
of the Dragon' is there was a text from George
and there was a little bit more of a roadmap."
Set more than 5,000 years before Game of Thrones,
the canceled show Bloodmoon was not planning
to feature any of the Game of Thrones characters
we already know and love.
As a matter of fact some of the houses and
families did not even exist in this time period,
like Targaryens for example. According to
HBO's official synopsis, the Bloodmoon was
meant to tell the story of "the world's descent
from the golden Age of Heroes into its darkest
hour."
It planned to centre around the Children of
the Forest and how they created the first
White Walker we now know as the Night King.
A teaser for the series said it would reveal
the “horrifying secrets of Westeros’s
history to the true origin of the White Walkers”.
The Age of Heroes is the name given to the
period in time which saw the First Men and
the Children of the Forest come together to
agree on a peace pact. This happened around
10,000 years before the first Game of Thrones
episode is set.
It ended around 7,000 years later with the
Coming of the Andals. The exact time the Age
of Heroes ended is not clear as different
sources in Westeros gave different accounts.
This meant that the fans would not know for
sure when the Bloodmoon was set –
the only details confirmed were that it's
the Age of Heroes era.
Casey Bloys, the President of HBO Programming,
told Deadline: "One of the things I think
Jane took on beautifully, which was a challenge,
there was a lot more world creation because
she set hers 8,000 years before the original
show, so it required a lot more.'' He added:
"We would have been very lucky to do one pilot,
have that pilot go and be a success, but in
development as you know, it takes a lot of
tries to get it right. This is no different."
In an interview with Entertainment Weekly,
the creator George R.R Martin stated that
Bloodmoon prequel was supposed to be set roughly
5,000 years before the events of Game of Thrones.
"We are dealing with a different and older
world," Martin told EW.
In the interview George R.R Martin also said
"Westeros is a very different place." King's
Landing will not even exist yet, and as a
result, there's no Iron Throne, either. Meanwhile,
Valyria will have "hardly begun to rise,"
Martin explained. "it's not the story we think
we know." It will teach us more about Westeros
history, the white walkers origins, and "the
mysteries of the East." In his interview with
The New York Times, Martin stressed that the
Long Night prequel was "mostly" the creation
of Jane Goldman.
In his own words: "If you look at the published
books so far, there's really very little material
about the Age of Heroes and the Long Night
— a sentence here, a sentence there. Old
Nan tells a tale that takes up a paragraph.
So Jane had to create the characters, the
settings and some of the events,
and we had to look at everything that was
said and say, 'O.K., here’s what was said
at this point, we need to make it consistent
to that.' We kicked around some ideas and
I made some suggestions. But mostly it's been
Jane running with it." Martin therefore explained
that he did not create the plot outline, characters,
or setting details for the Long Night TV series.
It was announced by HBO on October 29, 2019
that plans to produce the Long Night spin
off had been scrapped. After viewing the pilot,
HBO was not "thrilled by the results" and
even gave showrunner Jane Goldman and her
team notes on changes needed,
but even after the re-edit of the pilot HBO
was still "not thrilled" and decided not to
green light the pilot to series. Hours after
the cancellation that same day, HBO green
lighted instead another Game of Thrones prequel
direct to series that's co-created by George
R.R. Martin & Ryan Condal.
Condal will be a co-showrunner with famous
Game of Thrones director Miguel Sapochnik
who will also work on the pilot and additional
episodes in the prequel series called House
of the Dragons. House of the Dragon will draw
from George R.R. Martin's novel Fire & Blood,
which reveals more about the history of the
Targaryens.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
Thats Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Vlood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
Some would think that you could just read
the book Fire & Blood to know what will happen
in the show based on that very same book but
thats far from truth. Why?
Beacuse Fire And Blood is not a non conventional
novel, it is imaginary history book, and according
to George RR Martin himself, not very accurate
at that.
Because while Fire And blood book was written
by George RR Martin, it wasn't written from
him as facts, but rather through the perspective
of the Citadel's Archmaester Gyldayn who gathered
all the info and as many different sources
as he could and used it to write a book about
the Targaryen history. Some info is fake,
some info is true, some info is semi true.
No one will know for a fact what was happening
in the real history until the House
of the Dragon airs
in 2022.
The show unlike the book will contain truth,
it will depict what actually happened, not
the changed history, fake or semi true, not
what might or might not have happened.
The key event of House of the Dragon will
be the Targaryen civil war, the Dance of the
Dragons.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne. When people started declaring
for one of them or the other, their fight
divided the kingdoms in two. Targaryens fought
Targaryens, bothers fought brothers, dragons
fought dragons. By the time it was over, thousands
were dead. The conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only House
Targaryen, but large parts of Westeros as
well. In addition, it devastated the Targaryen's
dragon population, ultimately leading to their
extinction within a few decades.
They never truly recovered.
By the end of the reign of King Viserys I
Targaryen, twenty dragons were alive. The
majority of these died during the civil war
called the Dance of the Dragons, which began
in 129 AC and lasted until mid 131 AC.
Dozens of major battles, even more smaller
battles, and even more betrayals, turncloaks,
and twists.
All of that this Game of Thrones prequel show,
House of the Dragon, brings in 2022.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did make sure to give
it a big thumbs up. Hope to see you in the
next one, peace!